i am thrilled to report to you
that the joe biden administration has
frozen u.s weapons sales
to saudi arabia the biden administration
is freezing two big arms deals with
saudi arabia as well as the united arab
emirates
and these were approved very late in the
trump administration and they are now
on pause this is related to the sale of
some f-35
jets as well as attack drones to the uae
and a very big supply of various
munitions
elements of munitions to saudi arabia
these are stopped and they are going to
be reviewed this would be
a huge policy shift from the trump era
and really a big policy shift in general
for the united states state state
department
um and we have been talking about the
has it been i think it's been a decade
that i've been talking about
the perverse relationship with saudi
arabia on this program
um the senior u.s official who commented
on this
said that these are routine
administrative actions typical to any
transition you just
were putting a pause to review pending
arms deals
and they sort of are seemingly trying to
downplay the geopolitical significance
but i don't think it should be
downplayed
let's wait and see what they decide if
then they say in a month
oh yeah we're going to just go through
with it uh well then
maybe really this is no big deal but so
far this
appears to be a significant a
significant decision that's being made
i like what i see now uh
if we think about engagement with the
progressive base of the democratic party
as well as more left-leaning
independents this is a good step
by the biden administration of course it
remains to be seen
what ultimately happens with these
paused deals
but so far there is a lot to be
optimistic about and and very
importantly
this reminds us both sides aren't the
same trump
spent his administration bragging about
arms deals with saudi arabia when asked
about
stopping the deals over the murder of
jamal khashoggi
he said well there's a lot of jobs out
there remember this
jamal khashoggi the journalist the saudi
journalist
was he murdered by the saudis and did
the prince
give the order to kill him nobody knows
yet but we'll probably be able to find
out
it's being investigated it's being
looked at very very strongly
and we would be very upset and angry if
that were the case as of this moment
they deny it and did not deny it
vehemently could it be them yes
jared your son-in-law got on the phone
and asked the prince
did he what did he deny it did he they
deny it they denied every way you can
imagine
in the not too distant future i think
we'll know an answer what are your
options let's say they did what are your
options
would you consider imposing sanctions as
a bipartisan group
of senators have proposed it depends on
what the sanction is i'll give you an
example
they are ordering military equipment
everybody in the world wanted that order
russia wanted it china wanted it we
wanted it
we got it so would you cut that off
what i don't want to do boeing lockheed
raytheon all these i don't want to hurt
jobs
here's another one where donald trump
was asked about the same thing
be in favor of stopping a country from
spending 110
billion dollars which is an all-time
record
and letting russia have that money and
letting china have that money because
all they're going to do is say that's
okay
we don't have to buy it from boeing
we don't have to buy from lockheed we
don't have to buy it from
raytheon and all these great companies
we'll buy it from russia
we'll buy it from china so what good
does that do us
there are other things we can do now
donald trump is not wrong i mean
trump is right that there are u.s there
are jobs in the united states
connected to selling weapons to saudi
arabia that's
true what makes the freeze all the more
notable
and if they stick to it and cancel the
deals
all the more brave is that there are
jobs connected to this and there will be
people who say
anything that creates jobs must be done
no matter how unethical or immoral or
counter to our stated values as a
country
if joe biden sticks with not going
through with these sales
there will be some jobs on the line
that's true and it will make what is a
morally correct decision
all all the more uh significant i didn't
expect to see this yesterday
and i am quite pleased we will follow it
to see where it ends up
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at deepakman
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called
teddy stratford i love these shirts and
that's why i asked them to be a sponsor
of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because
all of their shirts come with a patented
zipper
hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but most importantly
just overall it makes the shirt fit much
better and look better the carefully
designed
shirt is also cut in a way that improves
the look of your upper body physique it
has a really nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed collar
that won't fall down and lay flat which
i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout